[Music]
baby watch 2018 is finally over for Eva
Longoria busting her little boy has
finally arrived I mean it feels like
she's been pregnant for like six years
it does even longer
I just wanted to numbers well he's here
for momma's kisses new mom Eva and her
husband Jose bastogne welcomed their son
Santiago Enrique bestowed yesterday in
Los Angeles weighing 6 pounds 13 ounces
the first time mom's seniors snuggling
her sweet newborn in this first photo
shared - hola USA with little Santiago
wearing his tiny Hospital beanie how are
you doing this the only thing that got
me here today was that there was food
when we spoke to you the last month we
encouraged her to sit and rest during
our brief chat where she revealed she
was told it was the last day at work
before giving birth but she wasn't
buying it I don't believe anybody I'm
gonna be giving birth on a dog show
somewhere throughout her first pregnancy
either used her Instagram to document
her growing belly and just two days
before giving birth to baby Santiago the
43 year old mom was celebrating the
World Cup with family
[Music]